hey friend you ready to get more out of
those body tracers earlier this month I
uploaded a tutorial on how to do
this so if you've gotten that down
you're probably ready to dive into
something new like maybe
this or
these or even
these we've got a lot of options for
using that knowledge you've picked up so
let's explore some exciting variations
that will push your PO game further
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm showing you what comes
next after you learn your vertical Poise
snakes but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys pyy light toys and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel peka
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission I've said it before and I'll say
it again po Spinners love to climb a
skill tree we enjoy learning new tricks
and seeing where they can take us in the
future but sometimes figuring out what
to tackle next can can be a bit
overwhelming what other tricks
complement what you've already mastered
are there variations on your current
skills that can push the boundaries
further and what related tricks should
you explore as well that's where this
series comes in what comes next is
designed to spark your creativity and
guide you on where to focus your efforts
next I'm here to help you take the
skills you've just learned and show you
three exciting options to expand and
enhance them and since the feedback on
my tutorial on vertical snakes earlier
in the month was overwhelmingly positive
I'm EXC exed to offer some fresh
guidance on where to go once you get
down that trick if you missed that video
I'll link to it down in the description
and up in the cards for you to check out
and of course if you love videos about
pois spinning and flow Arts make sure to
hit that subscribe button and ring the
bell to make sure that you know exactly
when I drop a new video and get a chance
to expand your knowledge even further
but for right now and without further
Ado what comes next after you learn
vertical po snakes starting with option
number one snakes in Split time
opposites now this is a pretty logical
next step if you gotten your vertical
snakes down in together time opposites
learning them in Split time opposites is
a great way to deepen your understanding
this is a variation made famous by Nikki
Evers wherein the Petals of the snakes
are looped around your shoulders
simultaneously rather than in Rapid
succession and because it's in Split
opposites it has that wow factor that
comes from a timing and Direction mode
at odds with the symetry of the human
body the really cool thing about split
time opposites is that it forces you to
think about timing and dire ction and
symmetry in a whole new way because the
human body has bilateral symmetry where
we reflect across a vertical axis tricks
and split time opposites add a lot of
visual interest because their symmetry
reflects across a horizontal axis plus
it's a great stepping stone to other
tricks that use this same timing and
direction trust me once you get the hang
of it you'll be glad you put in the
effort so this first pick was definitely
a pretty safe bet and the next one is
two but probably not in the way that
you're thinking option number two to
Turning with vertical
snakes isn't this just the same trick
that we started this whole conversation
with well yes and also no technically
vertical snakes are only a body Trac
around the segment that goes up your
body the route back down is just simply
an extension this variation turns the
way up as well as the way down into a
body Tracer making the whole trick fit
completely into this category the only
caveat here is that the same hand is
always doing the tracing but it still
looks incredibly cool to the audience
and will absolutely read as something
different from the original vertical
snakes that we were working with plus
which it requires you to turn and I'm
always a fan of poy tricks and
variations that get your body in motion
give this one a try and get those feet
in gear all right so we've explored
different timing and Direction
variations as well as how to turn the
entire trick into a body Tracer so let's
finish off with something that'll be
more of a challenge to your Tech
skills option number three adding caps
when I uploaded my vertical snakes
tutorial at the beginning of the month I
got a lot of people asking me whether it
was the same thing as a body Tracer
popularized by a PO spinner named G the
answer is that yes it is but it's a
simplified version of it the version of
vertical snakes that I always associate
with G involves performing caps on
either side of the body that's not the
only version of this trick that he
performed but to my mind it's absolutely
the most distinctive one this means
learning the hands together VAR of caps
to be able to perform as the hands work
their way down from above your head to
down back next to your hips the entire
trick becomes poly rythmic in the
process and the funny thing is the only
tweak you actually need to do in order
to get there is to pick one hand that
switches to anti-spin on the way down
the other hand is performing exactly the
same move this requires you to be really
comfortable with your anti-spin flowers
and caps but the results are surely
worth it and if you're interested in
deepening your knowledge of Po body
tracers by learning the fundamentals of
how they work year and luck because that
is the topic of the flow Circle for
August the flow circle is a weekly
exclusive lesson that's available only
to my patreon supporters and this month
we're focusing in on body tracers
everything from the basic skills of
using reels and linear isolations all
the way up to figuring out specific
moves like Archer weave fountains and
even a recipe by which you can turn Most
flowers into body tracers as well to
check that out go sign up over at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy the final
lesson of the month goes live on
Wednesday what were some of your
favorite tricks and techniques that
learning vertical snakes opened up did I
miss a few drop me a comment and let me
[Music]
know this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission if you're out there watching
this and you enjoyed this video please
consider signing up to help me make more
like it in the future you can do that by
heading on over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of excellent rewards but better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world do check
that out please and thank you and if
you've got the body tracing bug and are
excited to learn more I'd recommend
checking out my video on the top five
body tracers you should know I'll link
to it up on screen as well as down in
the description hopefully there's
something else there that inspires you
too thank you so much for watching now
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with another video real
soon take care now peace